so bro so he's always hitting on every
girl I never hit on you Rex you're
nothing like your best friend Robbie
he's shy and more than a little awkward
but you you say whatever's on your mind
you have no filter and you aren't afraid
to flirt with girls but the biggest
difference between you and Robbie is
that your head drastically shrunk in
size whereas Robbie's well Robbie's
pretty much stayed the same throughout
the series
so we hate to ask but are you the same
puppet we saw in the pilot episode
because it really doesn't look like it
Rex power spontaneous face change isn't
the only mistake fans noticed in
victorious in fact this show has tons of
unforeseen goofs from plot holes to
continuity errors to audio problems but
even then victorious is still one of the
best TV shows ever proving that nothing
not even victorious is perfect keep
watching to find out about the hilarious
hair nut goof we spotted in the episode
how Trina got in a lot of goofs happen
in the one-hour special titled Tori goes
platinum this is a really fun episode
because we get to see Tori sporting a
bunch of new looks
Tori wins a contest and lands herself a
gig at the Platinum Music Awards Tori
Vega how would you like to sing the
opening number this is Jade metals and
manages to snatch tours roll away from
her to cheer Tori up Andre Robbie and
Baek go to Tori's house and give her a
chocolate leaf blower but when Tori
tells Robbie and Andre that they can go
to the awards they run out of her place
and Robbie steals the gift they brought
her in the next shot however is the blue
and pink gift bag is still on the floor
there's another continuity error in the
episode two earlier in the series it was
revealed that Tori couldn't play any
instruments as mentioned in episodes
like stage fighting and a Becks big
break but in Tori's audition tape we see
her playing the piano like a pro while
she could have learned how to play on
her own she was playing in an unusually
skilled banner for a beginner no I did
Jade West isn't the easiest person to go
along with she's opinionated sarcastic
and quite frankly she can be a little
mean and scary that's not to say that
there isn't a nice person beneath that
stone-cold exterior in the episode
titled the wood a reality TV show called
the wood is filmed at Hollywood Arts the
students step in front of the camera to
tell the show's executives a little bit
about themselves and one of the
producers asked Jade's name a few things
that she doesn't like Jade goes on a
hate rant and the first thing she says
tuna fish we wouldn't call Jade a liar
but we know for a fact that Jade quite
likes it so much so that she's eating
tuna fish sandwiches for lunch before in
the episode titled robber Ozzy Robbie
starts spying on his fellow classmates
and posting some very embarrassing
videos of them online he posts a video
of Baek and Jade talking in a car and
it's here that Jade states that she ate
tuna fish for lunch while it isn't the
biggest continuity error it does make
Jade look a little shady we mean why
would she lie about hating tuna fish on
camera challenge but plot holes and
continuity errors aren't the only things
that made it into victorious the show
also had a handful of audio problems
when it came to syncing voiceovers to
their videos turns out the episode
titled robber Ozzy had more goofs than
one in this episode Robbie's minions
managed to snap pictures of Tori after
she's applied armpit cream to her
underarms Robbie
uploads the pictures to his blog but
seconds later we can see that Robbie's
lips don't match up with the audio it's
completely off but this wouldn't be the
first time Robbie's character
experienced audio problems and it
wouldn't be the last time either in the
episode titled to Tori the zombie we see
this happen yet again while Tori Beck
and Robbie are singing on stage Tory
hits Robbie and he says ow but his lips
are offbeat it's normal for actors to
record songs in the studio and later act
out the scenes while lip-syncing but
these two audio mishaps were way off
which is why viewers noticed them in the
first place you ready I think the real
question is are you ready
one of the funniest episodes in
victorious history is none other than
survival of the hottest during this
episode the Los Angeles area is hit with
a heat wave so the students decide to
take a well-deserved a mini road trip to
Venice Beach this episode has two
continuity errors and one major plot
hole the first error happens when Beck
and Jade get to the RV seconds before
Kat rushes out to use the bathroom keep
a close eye on Jade sunglasses they
disappear and reappear between takes a
handful of times then once in the RV the
game finds out that they're locked in
their only option is to wait for Kat to
come back from the bathroom
leading Jade to plop down on the couch
in the back of the RV but when the
camera switches over to Tori we can see
Jade sitting back down on the sofa but
the episodes biggest plot hole revolves
around the heat wave itself the gang was
stuck in the scorching RV without proper
ventilation for hours on end in real
life this would have stopped them from
fighting singing and talking because
well they would have been much too weak
to do anything at all give this video a
big thumbs up if you're enjoying it so
far and don't forget to subscribe to the
things for more fun videos we post
weekly videos about all your favorite
Nickelodeon shows so be sure to go into
your YouTube settings and switch on
notifications to get notified as soon as
we upload something new there are so
many things wrong with the episode
titled brain squeezers we don't even
know where to begin it all starts when
the gang is selected to appear on the
gameshow brain squeezers om RG
you got picked to be a team captain sure
did they pick teams and get ready to
battle it out on camera but there's
something seriously wrong with the host
of the show and the show itself first of
all all the contestants are minors and
you can't appear on TV without a legal
guardian signature secondly the show is
so violent it's a wonder that none of
the students were sent to the hospital
we mean come on
can't received a full-on blow to the
face the force the impact was so strong
it should have broken her nose at the
very least and then a car batteries
dropped on Jade's head for crying out
loud the entire brain squeezes crew
should have been sent to jail for
putting the lives of miners at risk then
when Jade gets her question wrong they'd
pummel her with salt and batteries but
the blue team's reaction to Jade's doink
was used twice in a matter of seconds
first when Jade was sprinkled with salt
and once again when the car battery fell
on her head this next TV mistake is a
little more subtle but that didn't stop
diehard victorious fans from calling it
out online in the pilot episode Andre
tries to convince Tory not to drop out
of Hollywood arts and then Robin wrecks
informs them that sicka wits wants them
to head back to the classroom
seconds later cat comes along to remind
the students that their teacher really
wants them to get back to class Rex goes
full savage on cat he mocks her saying
oh the pilot episode pretty much
confirms that Hollywood arts has hosted
a prom in the past but then in the
episode titled prom wrecker we hear the
students saying the exact opposite of
that Tori even talks to sicka wits and
tells him that Hollywood arts has never
had a prom before wait why are we
talking about proms
in the opening scene of the episode
titled a touring Jade's playdate
sicko wit to ask scat Robbie to deliver
some bad news and a happy wave now
improvise a scene where you have to give
Tanner that bad news in a way it doesn't
upset him so Robbie and cats to tell
Tanner the bad news while singing and
playing the guitar during this scene we
can see that Rex is sitting on a chair
in the background he's facing right
throughout the song but after the bad
news has been delivered Rex is looking
the other way
we seriously hope that Rex can't move on
his own because that would be way too
freaky then midway through the episode
sicko wits forces
Tori and Jade to go on a sushi date to
better learn how to play husband and
wife the girls aren't too happy about
this but if you keep an eye on Tori's
glass of green tea throughout the scene
you can see that it mysteriously
disappears and reappears between takes
my date and I were wondering if you have
a flight of stairs we could throw
ourselves down it's hard to keep track
of every little detail when filming a
hectic episode like the one titled the
slap fight so that must be why there
were so many discrepancies in the game
short film socks and violins in this
episode cat on Drabek Tori Robby and
Jade are tasked with creating a short
film for one of their classes but
they're short on time because of their
obsession with social media 19 hours to
finish that short film the gang manages
to create a short film with minutes to
spare but viewers quickly notice some
continuity errors in their school
project at the beginning of socks and
violins Jade is wearing an eyepatch over
her right eye but after a few seconds
the eyepatch jumps to her left eye and
then back again it's so easy to spot
that we almost didn't notice what was
happening with Jade's drink at the
beginning of the video she had fruit in
her glass but throughout the short film
the fruits mysteriously disappear and
reappear to freak the freak out
in the first part of the episode of
freak the freak out the gang goes to a
karaoke bar and things get a little
intense Haley and Tara flirt with Beck
and Andre when Jade leaves to grab a
soda if you get nervous I'll hold your
hands
and Jade loses it on them when she sees
what's going on
Jaden Kat are challenged to a sing-off
and during their performance Jade grabs
the food off Hayley and Tara's plate and
throws it around but during the very
next take we can see that the plate of
food is untouched as if Jade had never
taken her anger out on that poor little
burger in the episode titled how Trina
got in torreón Robbie go to a sushi
restaurant and Robbie offers to pay the
bill because Tori helped him massage his
grandma's feet we know pretty weird
stuff
right but problem is Robbie left his
wallet at school so they can't pay for
the food that just ate the restaurant
owner puts them to work chopping squid
and at one point Tori and Robbie ripped
their hair nets off in a fit of rage but
in the next shot
Robbie still has his hairnet on although
it disappears a few seconds later and
that's a wrap on the 10 huge mistakes
that made it into victorious before you
go tell us who your favorite character
is in the comments oh and be sure to
tell us which ship you prefer bade or
bori thanks for watching give this video
a big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe for more we'll see you next
time
[Music]